Jim Carrey speaks out after Katriona  White's autopsy results are released the  actor's girlfriend was found dead in her  home in September  Tuesday the Los Angeles County Coroner  officially ruled her death a suicide  Thursday Kerry slammed at the coroner's  office for releasing so many details  about White's death including parts of  her suicide note the actor tells et when  I came to Hollywood to make it as a  comedian I soon learned that the details  of my private life would be handed out  to the media like free dinner vouchers I  never dreamed that the people I love  most in the world would also be on the  menu  what a shame Jim and Katriona dated on  and off for three years right after her  death he told ET he was quote shocked  and deeply saddened he served as a  pallbearer in her funeral in October